ちょっと遅くなったんですけど断ってきました今日今日はあれ
恋えっともスラーがねぇ
どんな以下の1ヶ月前ぐらいにちょっと話題になったあーん
あれですなんかキャベツのやつです
can
par ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ん
ちょっとまだ開けてないから何とも言えないんですけどこんな
う
意外感です最初でだときどう思いましたか
だっても
すごいもんだって
eme
これは悪意や悪意感じると言っちゃダメです
でももし団子ねん
やっぱこの日本をなんとか健康にしようと思って頑張って作ったんだと思いますよ
どうですか
全部者別ですよ設定今日本全国のモスバーガー3分もうすごいことなってますよ
他のお店な髪も芋虫だけですよはいこんな感じだん
どう説明すればいいかわからんちょっと待ってこれずフッキングになりそう
これたぶんなんだから出しちゃダメなやつだねもうスってなんかこういう知ると語れる
から
をで僕はひらめいたんだ借金ここでローさんのいる家を挟む
番像
使っていこうと思います
はいっ
ほらねっっ
もうやないちょっといただきます
めっちゃ目はベッツはないけど
この花バラになるかんがぁ
そこでパンつけたら野菜だけで見ないです何か垂れる滑っツアー
食べてほしいんですけど
食べ方には注意が必要ですね
そういうシーンでぜひ食べてみてください
5それぐらいやってその中の野菜を選んで異論なしでは何でぜひ食べてみてください
じゃん
持ってい
ん